[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin c'est Benjamin
saura bonjour monsieur Sora merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous je vous en
prie installez-vous confortablement
prenez votre temps je vais vous
présenter en attendant vous êtes
historien spécialiste de l'Algérie
auteur de ce livre qu'on va voir
l'arrivée de Constantine à Paris 1962
1972 s'est oséditions
de votre départ d'Algérie de votre
arrivée en France avec votre famille
c'est aussi le récit de votre passage de
l'enfance à l'âge adulte de votre
construction intellectuelle et politique
et ça dit aussi beaucoup de la société
française ce livre on va longuement en
parler mais d'abord pourquoi avoir
choisi de raconter cette histoire
aujourd'hui 60 ans après
mais parce que peut-être en vieillissant
je me suis aperçu qu'il fallait se
retourner vers son passé et puis
comprendre
qu'elle était mon rapport à la société
française qui était un rapport qui était
pas simple qui paraissait simple puisque
nous étions français en Algérie mais en
fait qui n'était pas si simple qui avait
été compliqué difficile il est évident
que ce qui s'est passé ce qui se passe
dans l'actualité
notamment ce qu'on appelle les problèmes
d'intégration assimilation les problèmes
de la jeunesse aujourd'hui vont inciter
aussi à réfléchir sur mon propre
parcours c'est à dire comment se situer
dans un monde différent comment
respecter ou pas des codes d'une société
qui est différente car la société était
différente même si nous étions français
c'est ça tout le toute la difficulté
d'ailleurs de cette histoire c'est que
nous étions ni des immigrés ni des
réfugiés
ni les étrangers des Français et
pourtant on était tous ensemble en même
temps on était tous ensemble en même
temps donc c'était cette question en
fait en rapport avec l'actualité qui m'a
intéressé évidemment on va revenir
longuement là dessus ces questions
d'assimilation d'intégration vous nous
en parler ça fait c'est avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui on va prendre votre
livre dans l'ordre avant l'arrivée vous
parlez du départ le départ de chez vous
vous êtes né à Constantine dans une
famille juive chez vous on parle arabe
et on vit avec les musulmans et ça se
passe sans tension
c'est un quartier j'ai dit aux musulmans
donc il y a à la fois des tensions et à
la fois de la convivialité il y a une
vie commune en fait fondamentalement il
y a une fille communautaire disons le
mot c'est à dire une vie ou à la fois
bon les gens qui appartiennent à la
communauté juive ensemble ceux de la
communauté musulmane vivait ensemble il
y avait aussi un quartier chrétien bien
entendu mais en fait c'est vrai que
quelquefois il y avait des situations à
la fois de convivialité et de
conflictualité c'est en fait c'était le
même monde vivait dans le même univers
1962 c'est le début la première date de
votre livre vous devez quitter l'Algérie
et vous le dites la douleur de l'exil
c'est avant tout celle de vos parents
oui en fait vous savez il y a beaucoup
de littérature sur le départ sur lexil
etc et en fait quand j'ai fait ce livre
je me suis aperçu que moi la différence
de mes parents et d'autres livres très
nombreux
j'étais plutôt content de partir c'était
ça la c'est ça un peu l'Origin c'est
qu'un enfant de 12 ans qui quittait
l'Algérie pour aller vers la France
c'était quelque chose de très important
sur d'idéalisation de la France aussi on
connaissait pas donc on allait vers
disons un territoire nouveau une espèce
modernité nouvelle donc il y avait une
sorte d'excitation en fait du départ
bon même si je savais quand même
consciemment ou inconsciemment qu'il
s'agissait pas d'un départ de vacances
qui s'agissait pas d'un départ disons
qu'il pouvait se faire avec un retour
mais que c'était un départ sans retour
mais il y avait quand même cette cette
volonté c'est entre guillemets j'allais
dire presque joie de pouvoir disons
découvrir un monde nouveau c'est dit
évidemment pas le cas de mes parents qui
était beaucoup plus âgé puisque mon père
avait 53 ans et ma mère 46 ans donc ils
étaient déjà très âgés et par conséquent
pour eux ça a été très très difficile
que d'envisager de refaire complètement
leur vie dans un pays qu'il connaissez
pas et c'est arrivé dans dans le pays au
début elle est beaucoup marquée par le
noir par la nuit vous dites on a décollé
on a quitté l'Algérie et puis tout d'un
coup il faisait nuit j'ai pas vu quand
on a quitté les terres algériennes puis
vous arrivez à Paris vous vous dites
c'est la Ville Lumière et vous tombez
sur le noir du périphérique c'est aussi
ça que vous retenez de votre arrivée en
France oui il y a beaucoup de ça parce
qu'effectivement et c'est une image bien
sûr c'est à dire que il y a ce décalage
entre le récit sur la ville lumière à
travers la littérature bien sûr après à
l'école et puis l'arrivée dans la
réalité dans le réel et c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose bien entendu c'est un
peu le propre d'ailleurs entre
guillemets de tous les immigrés entre ce
qu'il rêve ce qu'ils imaginent d'un pays
et puis en même temps il y a la réalité
mais ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire c'est qu'effectivement comme je
l'ai écrit dans ce livre je n'ai pas vu
la dernière image de l'Algérie il y a
toujours cette histoire de la dernière
image qui s'éloigne du bateau qui
s'éloigne du quai qui s'en va etc là
c'est pas le cas du tout on est passé
directement à la nuit et donc il y a eu
un effacement disons de cette histoire
et de ce pays un peu comme une sorte de
marque symbolique d'ailleurs quelque
part cette sorte d'effacement
instantanée
et en arrivant à Paris votre père vous
emmène en famille faire le tour de trois
lieux trois lieux symboliques
racontez-nous parce que c'était
effectivement quelqu'un de très
pris très amoureux de la France de son
histoire de sa culture donc il nous a
emmené au château de Versailles c'était
important de connaître le château de
Versailles et nous emmener aussi au Père
la chaise parce que il y avait beaucoup
de grands écrivains qui avaient été
ouvert la chaise etc puis comme on avait
atterri aussi dans une banlieue très
particulière qu'elle a banlieue de
Montreuil il y avait le château de
Vincennes qui était juste à côté de là
où nous habitions donc il y avait
effectivement les visites de ces lieux
symboliques de ce que représentait aux
yeux de mon père bien sûr ce que pouvait
représenter la France à la fois la
magnificence mais aussi les prisons les
donjons et aussi bien sûr ce qui peut
ouvrir représenter le rapport aux morts
le rapport à l'histoire longue à
l'histoire extrêmement ancienne et il y
avait la manière dont vous chantier la
France dont vos parents se représentait
la France et puis il y a la manière dont
vous avez été accueillis donc vous avez
vécu concrètement ce qui était l'arrivée
en France à quoi elle ressemble à France
de 1962 qui vous accueille ça n'a pas
été facile bah c'est une France en fait
qui veut oublier l'Algérie
fondamentalement parce qu'elle sort de
la guerre un million et demi de jeunes
soldats français entre 1957 et 1962 sont
partis en Algérie donc toutes les
familles françaises ou la plupart ont
été concernés par l'Algérie tout le
monde avait peur aussi de cette histoire
de cette guerre donc le passage à
l'indépendance a été pour les Français
ressentis comme une sorte aussi de
libération quelque part donc pour ce qui
fait du mauvais côté de l'histoire
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait pour ceux qui
arrivaient c'était pas la même histoire
bien entendu parce que perdez entre
guillemets un pays alors que ceux qui
étaient en métropole qui vivaient en
France vient dans le fond c'était une
histoire nouvelle qui commençait surtout
qu'on était dans la période des 30
glorieuses donc une France en pleine
expansion économique de pleine
modernisation aussi avec les grandes
entreprises en particulier industrielles
avec la politique très volontariste à
l'époque menée par le général de Gaulle
pour moderniser la France presque à
marche forcée donc il y avait par
conséquent un décalage très fort très
grand entre ceux qui arrivaient et puis
ceux qui vivaient à l'intérieur de la
société française et qui aspirait à plus
de consommation et de prospérité et
cette histoire vous allez la redécouvrir
grâce à René Raymond
cette histoire pardon excusez-moi votre
histoire de votre famille en tant
qu'historien est-ce que quand René
Raymond veut suggère de choisir la
Révolution algérienne comme champ
d’étude ça vous la faire redécouvrir oui
parce qu'en fait
je participais aussi de ce mouvement
général de la société c'est-à-dire on a
atterri aussi à Sartrouville dans une
banlieue ouvrière lointaine comme
beaucoup de personnes à l'époque etc
donc il y avait un oubli de l'Algérie il
y a eu 68 aussi bon je me suis engagé
comme la plupart des gens de machines
beaucoup de gens de ma génération il y
avait une fracture générationnelle très
importante une radicalité politique bien
sûr donc tout ça additionné fait qu'en
l'espace de quelques années bah on
oublie l'Algérie et puis arrivé à
l'université où je faisais mes études à
Nanterre et bien Jean-Pierre Riou et qui
était avec René Raymond mais mes
enseignants à l'époque on dit mais dans
le fond
Benjamin Story qui vous intéressez à
tous les pays du monde
je sais pas vous savez on s'intéressait
à tout on regardait tous les pays et il
y en a un sur lequel vous attardez
jamais c'est bizarre c'est l'Algérie et
là j'ai réalisé qu'effectivement je
venais d'Algérie c'est à dire que
j'avais essayé d'oublier l'Algérie donc
de massimiler en fait à la Société
française mais l'Algérie me rattrapé sur
le pied par le biais disons du savoir
académique et du savoir universitaire
parce que pour vous assimiler il fallait
oublier vous raconter aussi le
détachement progressif vis-à-vis de vos
parents oui tout à fait c'est-à-dire que
la question de la similation à la
société d'accueil de la France a été
effectivement un moment d'oubli
de ce que pouvait représenter une vie
antérieure une vie communautaire à base
de traditions religieuse par exemple etc
c'était une grande rupture le fait
d'arriver en France dans la mesure où ma
famille qui était très grande une très
grande famille du côté de mon père et de
ma mère a été dispersé en fait la grande
question c'était celle de la dispersion
familiale aux quatre coins de l'hexagone
et par conséquent cette dispersion
engendrait beaucoup de solitude et cette
solitude naturellement nous ramener à
l'oubli et essayer de se construire par
soi-même ce qui était le problème de mes
parents d'ailleurs fondamentalement
c'était d'essayer de vivre de se
construire et pas seulement de se
rappeler de l'Algérie mais fallait
trouver un travail trouver un logement
et ça a été simple et ça a été très
compliqué ça a été très long ça a été
très difficile pour raconter la solitude
de votre mère et ma mère en particulier
a été embauchée dans une usine elle est
devenue ouvrir d'usine ce qui est un
parcours exceptionnel pour une femme qui
n'avait jamais travaillé et qui s'est
retrouvé dans une usine Peugeot à La
Garenne Bezons donc à Sartrouville dans
une dans une banlieue lointaine donc
tous ces éléments conjugués fait
qu'effectivement l'Algérie c'était
éloigné de moi parce que tout ça allait
très très vite quand même très très vite
les études la modernisation de la
société la société de consommation la
musique la culture la culture d'avant et
d'après 68 toutes ces ruptures quand
même qui sont très très fortes très très
importantes fait que effectivement il y
a eu cette oubli si c'était installée
mais il est revenu je veux dire
l'Algérie et revenu dans ma dans ma
mémoire dans ma conscience par le biais
ensuite du savoir et du rocher de la
recherche universitaire vous parlez
beaucoup de l'assimilation vous nous en
parler encore ce matin qu'est-ce que ce
mot assimilation est veut dire pour vous
et est-ce qu'il a encore un sens dans la
France d'aujourd'hui moi je pense que
oui parce que l'assimilation c'est ça
similaire et des codes à des valeurs qui
sont d'abord celle de la République tout
simplement c'est à dire de rentrer dans
une société ou avec le l'adoption du
principe de l'égalité politique
notamment l'égalité homme-femme
l'égalité juridique l'égalité citoyenne
donc c'est ça la simulation pour moi
c'était d'accepter cette société qui
n'était pas une société réaliser
simplement en communauté juxtaposée mais
c'était
d'exister à l'intérieur d'un ensemble
d'un vivre ensemble qui était
naturellement celui qui était organisé
par la République donc l'assimilation
oui mais l'assimilation il y avait aussi
un inconvénient c'était qu'il fallait
effectivement ne pas montrer ses
origines c'est ce que j'explique dans le
dans le livre c'était difficile il y
avait quelque part une forme de
dissimulation des origines à travers le
processus de la civilisation donc il a
fallu à la fois pénétrer dans cette
société en y respectant les codes code
de la République mais en même temps en
essayant en soi de maintenir disons des
traditions une histoire antérieure une
histoire de l'origine ça a été ça a été
sans arrêt en fait ce va-et-vient
l'assimilation dans le fond elle
consiste dans ce va-et-vient
permanent mais qui est le propre de
beaucoup d'immigration en fait ne pas
montrer ses origines et ne pas montrer
sa religion on vous racontez aussi la
conception différente du judaïsme que
vous avez découverte en arrivant en
France vous dites c'était pas pareil le
judaïsme en Algérie le judaïsme en
France et vous avez cette phrase c'est
stricte séparation entre croyances
privées et pratiques publiques m'inscrit
dans la société française elle
m'assimile comment vous regardez les
débats d'aujourd'hui sur la religion
notamment sur les signes religieux dans
l'espace public à l'école il y a eu en
cette rentrée un débat sur la Bahia
qu'elle regarde vous avez là-dessus
effectivement vous avez raison de de
souligner le fait que le regard que je
portais sur la religion n'était pas le
même parce que le la vie que je menais
en Algérie était une vie religieuse
communautaire où tout était réglé régie
par la question religieuse par exemple
la cuisine les plats alimentaires les
cuisines étaient liées au fait
religieuses donc il y avait toute une
organisation de la vie matérielle qui se
faisait en fonction disons de la vie
religieuse ce qui n'était pas le cas
naturellement de notre
que lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
France donc lorsque j'observe cela bien
sûr
cette question
c'est modifié bien sûr parce que
effectivement autant le temps des années
60 des années 70 la question de
l'identité dans le fond se posait assez
peu parce qu'il y avait d'abord le plein
d'emploi donc il y avait pas disons
cette recherche disons d'un travail de
manière désespérée donc ça c'est très
important il y avait aussi disons une
république qui se voulait davantage
égalitariste et davantage citoyenne etc
une classe politique qui se posait pas à
cette question qui ne se posait pas le
problème ils ont de d'une émigration qui
pouvait être séparée du reste de la
société française toutes ces questions
ont explosé littéralement récemment
c'est à dire depuis des années 80
fondamentalement et c'est depuis des
années 80 que la question de
l'appartenance religieuse est revenu sur
le devant de la scène vous l'expliquez
comment
dans les années 80
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
pigeons il y a plusieurs explications
possibles il y a d'abord à mon sens le
reflux des idées politiques collectives
la crise de du libéralisme politique la
crise du socialisme français du
communisme aussi qui a disparu à
l'époque tous ces instruments là étaient
des instruments de socialisation
extraordinaire moi je me rappelle dans
la banlieue de Sartrouville ou je vivais
le Parti communiste était très très fort
pour organiser les loisirs le sport etc
etc c'était beaucoup moins le cas bien
sûr par la suite dans les années 80 donc
il y a d'abord un affaiblissement de
cela un affaiblissement de l'idée d'un
progressisme c'est-à-dire qu'on va aller
vers plus de progrès il y a au contraire
l'image l'idée qui s'installe que dans
le fond la planète va mal et il y a un
repli individualiste c'est à dire pas
sauver soi-même c'est à dire que
paradoxalement la montée religieuse
selon moi elle va de père aussi avec une
montée de l'individualisme c'est-à-dire
que c'est ça va de pair c'est à dire que
ça peut paraître un peu paradoxal ce que
je dis mais c'est en fait de se sauver
soi-même et retrouver le sens d'une
communauté protectrice donc c'est dans
cette crise des idéologies politiques
aujourd'hui elle ne fait plus que c'est
plus une communauté pour les gens c'est
ça aussi la nation doit se redéfinir
elle doit se redéfinir sans arrêt
d'ailleurs parenthèse c'est pas des
questions nouvelles elle se posait déjà
au 19e siècle se poser avant à chaque
fois on a l'impression on a le sentiment
que la question de l'identité nationale
est une question tout est totalement
originale nouvelle etc bah non c'est une
question qui se qui se pose
la fin du 19e siècle avait l'histoire de
l'Alsace-Lorraine qui était évidemment
extrêmement importantes il y a eu entre
deux guerres bien sûr avec la question
du racisme
les gardes étrangers il y a eu un
exemple de Vichy bien sûr enfin je vais
pas faire ici toute l'histoire de France
mais ça a été sans arrêt sans cesse une
bataille pour redéfinir la notion d'un
vivre ensemble et d'une nation qui se
construit dans la citoyenneté c'est le
cas aujourd'hui c'est encore une
bataille c'est à nouveau une bataille et
puis à la présence aussi il faut dire
d'une nouvelle religion en France qui
est l'Islam qui n'existait pas disons de
manière aussi importante dans les années
60 mais qui existait déjà mais le fait
effectivement qui est la présence disons
d'une nouvelle religion en France oblige
la République à réfléchir davantage sur
la place de cette religion dans la
société française qu'elle ne fait pas
suffisamment selon vous
ce qu'elle a du mal à faire à la fois il
y a cette ce retard disons de réflexion
sur le regard porté sur cette religion
mais il y a aussi le fait que du point
de vue de l'Islam il faut aussi le
dégagement d'institutions représentative
communautaire et d'intellectuel disons
capables aussi de porter cette parole de
porter cette civilisation parce que
l'islam se passe simplement une religion
c'est une civilisation et donc cela par
contre
c'est difficile parce qu'on l'a pas
précisément on est on est dans cet entre
deux pour l'instant
vous un mot quand même sur
l'antisémitisme vous dites vous vous
avez pas été confronté à antisémitisme
en Algérie vous y avez été confronté en
arrivant en France il y a une nouvelle
agression antisémite ces dernières
heures à Marseille en étudiant aux juif
de 21 ans qui portait une kippa qui
s’endelle à la synagogue et qui a été
agressé il y a une résurgence de
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays moi je
pense que oui il y a effectivement
plusieurs types d'antisémitisme qui
viennent s'additionner ce juxtaposer les
uns par rapport aux autres qui est très
inquiétant bien sûr rien que vous êtes
l'explique c'est très dangereux
il y a plusieurs facteurs
dans les situations de crise sociale et
à la recherche du bouc émissaire à celui
qui est responsable de la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes alors c'est ceux
qui tirent les ficelles de l'arrière bon
ça va de pair aussi avec ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui entre guillemets le
complotisme c'est-à-dire bon ben il y a
le devant de la scène les médias les
hommes politiques etc et puis derrière
agissant dans l'ombre il y a des
personnages
disons qu'ils décident de la destinée du
monde et bien c'est une vieille
conception là aussi qui revient qui
ressurgit au fur et à mesure des crises
que le pays traverse que la France peut
traverser donc oui je crois que on a
assisté à un retour un regain disons de
l'antisémitisme parce qu'aussi ça
renvoie ce que j'essaie tout à l'heure
il y a le risque disons d'un
communautarisme séparé le risque d'un
individualisme bien sûr qui est très
très grand et donc le risque de ne pas
continuer à faire nation parce que il
faut savoir que les Juifs en fait comme
les musulmans aussi d'un certain point
de vue appartiennent à la nation
française ils sont dans l'histoire de la
République française et on passe séparer
de cette histoire
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la page de la
décolonisation est tournée selon vous
pas tout à fait
pas tout à fait je vois le sens de votre
question à peu près par rapport à ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en Afrique vous
savez lorsque le président Manuel Macron
est arrivé au pouvoir il a prononcé un
discours à Ouagadougou je crois en 2017
où il avait bien conscience qu'il
fallait aussi
en finir avec ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque la France Afrique c'est-à-dire
la décolonisation pas simplement sur le
plan économique mais également sur le
plan des imaginaires donc la restitution
d'objets la restitution de tableaux qui
étaient très souvent d'ailleurs des
objets sacrés pour pour les pays
africains notamment et même d'Afrique du
Nord bien sûr donc c'est décolonisation
là sur le plan culturel notamment et
c'est pas véritablement accompli alors
il y a la décolonisation économique la
dépendance des liens avec l'ancienne
métropole coloniale bien entendu mais
pour ce qui me concerne ce qui
m'intéresse personnellement par exemple
dans la réconciliation franco-algérienne
puisque le président a chargé de faire
un rapport sur cette question ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est aussi celle des
symboles c'est à dire le fait que les
nations en construction en
reconstruction récupère ce réappropries
leur souveraineté on récupérant des
objets des manuscrits qui qui
appartiennent à leur propre histoire et
que la France doit restituer je crois
qu'il y a tout un il y a tout un travail
de réflexion à mener en France
aujourd'hui sur cette question de la
restitution travail qu'on a commencé
d'ailleurs à mener à travers l'existence
d'une commission mixte d'Historia
français et algérien qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui dénoncent à un
exercice de repentance
moi je veux bien qu'on dénonce la
repentance et encore faut-il qu'elle
existe je veux dire à ma connaissance il
y a pas tous les matins des discours
d'hommes politiques français qui
s'excuse ou qui non il y a pas ça pardon
il y a
au contraire une situation où on
continue d'avancer
sur un sur un mode qui est celui de la
fin de cette histoire des colonies
depuis très longtemps or c'est pas vrai
on a cru qu'il fallait oublier qu'il
fallait en finir c'est d'ailleurs le
l'objet de ce livre c'est le fait
d'avoir oublié sans jamais vraiment
oublier c'est-à-dire d'être encore
disons dans cette situation de traces
qui qui continue d'agir et de
fonctionner donc par conséquent oui
la repentance
disons elle est beaucoup invoquée mais
c'est surtout un argument à mon sens qui
est plus un argument polémique
idéologique politique qu'un argument de
réalité
et les peuples en Afrique aujourd'hui
très franchement on parle sentiment que
la France est fait une repentance
quelconque ça il suffit il suffit
d'aller passer quelques jours et des
travailler en Afrique pour le savoir
comment vous les qualifier aujourd'hui
les relations franco-algériennes
ce sont des relations difficiles parce
que vous savez la France est restée 132
ans en Algérie c'est considérable c'est
sur des générations et des générations 5
6 7 générations donc on peut pas dénouer
une histoire aussi longue par un seul
discours par un seul mot ou par un seul
geste il y a tout un travail à mener qui
est très long c'est ce travail que nous
commençons seulement maintenant à mener
c'est à dire de reconnaissance pas de
repentance mais de reconnaissance de ce
qui a été fait pendant ces 132 ans bon
il y a déjà un certain nombre de gestes
qui ont été faits par le Président de la
République il y en a d'autres qui
suivront je pense donc il y a tout un
travail de pédagogie encore comme geste
du président de la République
il faudra qu'on continue par exemple
l'examen des archives sur la question
disons de ce qui s'est passé en Algérie
mais aussi la question de disparu et
puis les essais nucléaires donc qui ont
eu lieu notamment au Sahara etc donc il
y a encore beaucoup je peux citer
d'autres d'autres exemples il y a
énormément d'exemples parce que
malheureusement on a trop eu tendance va
avoir les rapports franco-algériens sur
un registre extraordinairement
psychanalytique traumatisme etc il y a
des questions très pratiques très
réelles la question des cimetières par
exemple c'est des questions très
importantes pour faire le travail de
deuil d'une histoire donc il faut
s'atteler à un exercice de travaux
pratiques en fait fondamentalement dans
les rapports franco-algériens c'est ce à
quoi on essaie de s'atteler aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut que ça aille dans les
deux sens est-ce qu'il faut aussi des
gestes du côté d'Alger tout à fait il
faut que ça aille dans les deux sens
parce que évidemment il faut aussi que
tu côtais algérien et un certain nombre
de gestes qui soient faits qui est aussi
l'ouverture des archives qui soit
accomplies du côté algérien facilia des
archives en Algérie et qui les
chercheurs algériens d'ailleurs
eux-mêmes réclament à l'ouverture de ces
archives je prends cet exemple parce
qu'il paraît particulièrement important
pour un historien donc il y a
effectivement des gestes à faire de part
et d'autre mais quand même la France a
été la puissance colonisatrice donc
c'est d'elle qu'on attend aussi bien sûr
le plus grand nombre de signes est-ce
que cette histoire douloureuse entre la
France et l'Algérie elle explique aussi
en partie la brouille actuelle entre la
France et le Maroc oui et non
oui parce qu'effectivement le fait de se
rapprocher de l'Algérie n'a pas plu
effectivement aux autorités marocaines
mais
c'est pas simplement une question de
jalousie
on va privilégier un rapport plutôt
qu'un jour je crois pas je crois plus
fondamentalement il y a le problème du
Sahara c'est le problème du Sahara le
problème du Sahara occidental et de la
position française qui est une position
médiane qui est une position
intermédiaire sur entre la question de
l'autonomie de l'indépendance et du
référé d'homme possible
d'autodétermination au Sahara qui a fait
se creuser au fur et à mesure des années
passées la divergence entre la France et
le Maroc ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
depuis très longtemps depuis très
longtemps depuis pratiquement les années
70 depuis ce qu'on a appelé la Marche
Verte
c'est très vieux vous voyez et bien
effectivement les autorités marocaines
attendent davantage toujours de
clarification politique des positions
françaises sur la question du Sahara qui
ne vient pas d'autant que aux États-Unis
bah les choses ont évoluées les choses
ont changé donc la situation
géopolitique a changé merci Benjamin
Stora merci infiniment d'avoir été notre
invité merci pour cette entretien
passionnant je rappelle le titre de
votre livre l'arrivée de Constantine à
Paris on le voit
1962-1972 c'est aux éditions